[Music]
what's up guys I'm going be showing you
a moneymaking guide that involves bird
nests and mole skins and mole claws so
what you're going to want to do you're
going to want to buy your mole skins and
your mole Claws and then you're going to
want to teleport to the fador area on
your ring of dueling it'll take you to
the garden and then you'll run over here
to the right and you'll talk to one of
the gardeners and so the max bu limit on
mole Claws and mole skins is 50 per four
hours I believe so if you want to do
this hourly you're going to need to buy
a lot in advance so once you get to him
you're going to talk to him and say I
want to trade my um my mole Parts in for
some bird's nest and he's going to give
you some
boxes and then you're going to come back
to the GE you're going to go ahead and
put the boxes in there and quick note in
order to make profit from this method
the bird the crushed bird's nests and
the mole claws M skins need to be
anywhere between 500 GP to 1,000 GP
difference so either positive or
negative so so for either one so if the
bird's nest the crush Nest is going for
8K and the mole claws are going for 7K
then that's okay if the mole claws are
going for 8K and the bird's n one for 7K
then that's okay but they just need to
be about a 1K difference or 500 GB to
make a to make um profit and so once you
do it you're going to want to take your
boxes out and this is the the ones with
that have all the Rings in them you're
going to open all them
up and then you're going to go ahead and
put them in there and then you're going
to do the same thing for the bird's nest
and for the empty Birds Nest so what
you're going to want to do you're going
to want to take all the boxes out and
you want to just keep opening them
you're going to want to put them back
open them again and get all the nests
out and then once you have the nests out
you want to open them all up and try to
keep all the seeds in your inventory so
you don't lose track of them in case you
have some in your bank that way you know
the profits you're actually
making and just keep doing this until
all the seeds are
done and then once the seeds are done
what we're going to do we're going to
take out the nests and a pestl and
mortar
and then we're going to go ahead and
crush
them all right it's almost
done okay now that it's done we're going
to want to take out our mortar take out
our bird's
nest and we're just going to want to
start crushing them so use your pestl
and mortar on the bird's nest and just
crush them and from my last video I
found that it was profitable to just
Crush normal bird's nests into Crush
nests and sell them so that's profitable
too if you want to check out my last
video that'll help you out so just crush
them it'll take like it'll take very
little time maybe 2 minutes to do 100
maybe one minute not
sure all right I am done so now I will
sell them all and show you guys what I
make okay so I'm done selling
them and we'll go ahead and subtract
what we bought them for from what we
made so let's see how much we made first
um okay 87 756 okay 817
minus the
,000 and minus the 3
60150 so 91k so we'll times the 91k
times
the um it took about 3 minutes to do
this so we'll do the 60 minutes divided
by 3
minutes so 20 so 20 *
91 606 so 1.8 mil okay so that's without
doing the Rings so now let's do the
rings so with the
Rings forgot to add this in so we'll add
this in real quick to the
math so we'll go ahead and look at the
history again so 82
8K minus the
366,000 that we had from the mole skins
and now minus the mole claw
360 1 15 100 okay 101k basically times
20 2 mil so you can make 2 mil making
this method that's insane profits for
very little requirements stay tuned for
my next
[Music]
video